Hi. In this lecture we're gonna talk about
bringing modules to data and when I say
data what I mean is you know you. Pull all
sorts of numbers off the web, or maybe
you've got you know, in you?re, for your
business or your home you got all this
data out there and how much money you've
spent each month or something like that.
We [inaudible] how we can use models to
understand that data. And we're gonna
start simple and we're gonna build up. So
we're gonna start with something that I
call categorical models. Now in a
categorical model what you do is you just
sort of place all the different data in
different boxes. So for example, suppose
you had a bunch of data on how long people
live, and you want to try to understand
what. Allows someone to live a long and
healthy life. We might create one box of
people who exercise and one box of people
who don't exercise and we can just, by
looking at how much variation there is in
each of those boxes and what the means are
in those two boxes you can figure out does
that distinction make that categorization
between exercising and not exercising,
does that actually help understand all the
variation in the data? After you do
categorical models we're gonna move on to
linear models. Now why don't I give a
distinction between a linear model and a
line. So a line is just something that we
plot, right? So we just have like, you
know, here's the Y variable, here's the X
variable, and we draw this line. In a
linear model what we assume is we assume
that this Y variable depends on X. Right?
And so what this is, is this, this is some
sort of relationship. So in this axis, X
could literally be the amount of exercise
you do, and Y could be how long you live.
And so what you have is this line is sort
of saying that how long you live is a
function of how much you exercise. So
you're literally thinking [inaudible] Y.
Is some function of X. Okay, so after we
do linear models, and I explain what they
mean. And I have a short lecture sort of
describing how we fit data to linear
models. So if you've got a bunch of data,
and then you wanna construct a linear
model, how do we do it? Here's a simple
example. Suppose I've got a bunch of data
here like this. And I want to ask, you
know what's the best line to go through
that data? Well clearly this would be a
terrible line because it doesn't, it's not
near the data. This line here that they've
done this black line looks like a pretty
good line. It looks pretty close to the
data, so we're going to see how exactly to
draw the line and what criteria do you
use, right, to make sure you've got the
best line? After we've done linear models,
we're gonna move nonlinear models. And
we'll show that the techniques are
actually fairly similar. Now, what do I
mean by nonlinear? Well, one simple way
that somebody could be nonlinear, is they
could start out straight and then kind of
flatten out. Or, something could start out
slow, and then get big. Or it could sorta
do both. It could start out slow, and then
get big, and then flatten out, right? So
there's all different shapes a function
could take. You know, John Von Neumann,
one time, said, the set of non linear
functions is like the set of non
elephants. And by that, he meant that the,
the number of non linear functions is
enormous. So we'll talk a little bit about
how we could use some of the same
techniques used for linear models to
create non linear models. Now after we do
that we're gonna conclude this, this unit
by talking about something I call the big
coefficient. So what do I mean? Well when
you have a linear model, right? You have
like Y equals A1, X1 plus A2, X2. So X1
and X2 are the variables. These are the
things that determine the outcome. So
we'll talk about for example school
quality. So X1 might be what the class
size is. And X2 might be how good the
teacher is. And so this A1 and A2 are the
coefficients, and these coefficients tell
how important is the variable. So the
bigger the coefficient, the more important
the variable. So when I say the big
coefficient. What I mean is making
policies or making the decision based on
which one of these coefficients is
biggest. Now that makes a lot of sense. So
what I'm gonna do is, I'm first going to
argue that boy, you know, better to use
the big coefficient then to just sort of
do seat of the pants thinking. We're going
to see why that's the case. Linear models
are just better, right? We've seen a
little of this before but we're going to
go into more detail. Linear models are
just better than just sort of thinking off
the cuff. Then I'm also going to criticize
a little bit, right? Because I'm gonna say
one problem with big coefficient is it
only works in the area in which we've got
the data. And oftentimes, if we want to
make the world a lot better place we have
to shift into an entirely new reality.
We've got to shift to a place where there
is no data. So I'm gonna draw distinction
between what I call the big coefficient,
and what I'm gonna call the new reality.
Brighter situations that are just maybe a
lot better than what we currently have.
Alright, so that's a summary of where
we're gonna go. We're gonna start out with
categorical models, then linear models,
show how to fit lines to data, right? And
we're gonna do some nonlinear models, and
then we'll wrap it all up by talking about
this idea of the big coefficient. Alright,
thank you.